pas bonjour à toutes et à tous l'europe
le berceau de l'humanité point
d'interrogation nouveau documentaire qui
vient d'être diffusé sur arte vous avez
été extrêmement nombreux à me demander
ce que j'en pensais avant même qu'il
soit sorti et j'ai finalement pu le voir
grâce à l'aide du camarade de la chaîne
parlons évolution donc je le salue merci
de m'avoir envoyé le documentaire parce
que d'afrique du sud en fait je ne peux
pas le voir
donc c'est gentil de me l'avoir envoyé
j'ai pu le regarder et du coup je peux
vous donner mon avis un petit avis
express au début de la vidéo juste pour
que vous vous fassiez une idée est ce
qu'il faut le voir ou pas et mon avis
est je suis à la fois soulagé et déçu
alors soulagé parce que le reportage est
pas si mal est déçu parce que ben
justement le reportage est pas si mal
que je m'attendais vraiment à voir un
documentaire digne d'un des bonnes kg
pénitence et puis en fait finalement il
n'était pas si mal il a il a quand même
quelques qualités donc je vais commencer
par les qualités
la plus grande qualité de ce
documentaire c'est que là au moins on
nous montre les fossiles voilà là au
moins les hypothèses qu'on développe on
nous dit on nous montre les fossiles qui
les soutiennent
voilà on nous montre pas seulement des
reconstitutions 3d des machins on nous
montre les fossiles et on nous montre
même les chercheurs qui ont vraiment
fait ses recherches donc les gens qui
présente le documentaire se sont
vraiment eux qui ont conduit les
recherches qui sont présentés dans le
documentaire
donc là au moins voilà on a un accès
direct à d'où vient la formation qu'on
nous donne et ça c'est beau et ça c'est
beau donc il est pas mal du tout ce
petit documentaire par contre il a un
énorme défaut là un énorme défaut et
c'est qu'il vous ment
ce documentaire est un énorme mensonge
il est construit sur un énorme mensonge
alors c'est pas que les fossiles qu'on
vous montre sont fausses et pas que les
gens qui parlent de dents sont des
menteurs c'est pas la théorie qu'il
défende qui sont qui est un mensonge
c'est le documentaire qui est un
mensonge
ce documentaire vous promet une origine
européenne de la lignée humaine donc par
lignée humaine j'entends la branche qui
a divergé des chimpanzés 1
je parle pas de l'origine d'homo sapiens
je parle pas de l'origine du genre homo
ou des australopithèques je parle bien
de l'origine de la lignée humaine après
la divergence avec les chimpanzés donc
ce documentaire vous promet une origine
de la lignée humaine en europe et à la
place ils vous donnent une origine
européenne de l'ancêtre commun du
chimpanzé du gorille et de l'homme donc
au lieu de vous filer une origine
européenne des homes in it avec un i
donc là regardez bien l'image que je
vous affiche à l'écran 1
si vous ne savez pas ce qu'est un ami ni
ni donc il vous promet une origine
européenne des eaux minini et à la place
ils vous le donne une origine européenne
des hominidés et ça ça fait une énorme
différence parce que l'origine une
origine non africaine de la lignée
humaine
ce serait révolutionnaire ce serait
incroyable de voir l'origine de l'homme
ne pas être africaine par contre une
origine européenne des hominidés de
l'ancêtre commun aux chimpanzés au
gorille et à la l'être humain ça par
contre ça rien de nouveau du tout ni de
révolutionnaire
pourquoi ça n'a rien de révolutionnaire
mais il suffit de regarder les grands
singes moderne
quel est le plus banal de tous les
grands singes moderne celle orangs
outans et l'orang outan il est en asie
donc je veux dire de les avoir des
grands singes ailleurs qu'en afrique on
sait déjà que ça existe c'est à voir
l'être humain ailleurs qu'en afrique qui
est qui est surprenant mais avoir des
grands singes ailleurs qu'en afrique
mais c'est pas du tout une surprise et
ça a été très bien formalisé depuis 2004
avec la découverte de pierrot la pythie
cus
ça a été très bien formaliser avec la
découverte d'une diversité gigantesque
de grands singes en europe
je veux dire l'un des premiers grands
singes fossiles qui a été découvert non
humain je veux dire c'est driot pittacus
et c'était à toulouse d'un cocorico
d'ailleurs donc voilà des grands singes
ailleurs qu'en afrique on sait déjà que
ça existe donc ce documentaire aussi
bien exécuté soit il vous ment il vous
sur vend dès le départ une origine
européenne de la lignée humaine et à la
place ils vous file une origine
européenne des hominidés
voilà mais ça il vous le révèle qu'à
partir de la 49e minute et pendant 40 49
minutes
il entretient un flou artistique sur ce
qu'il entend par l'origine de lui
and it et je suis désolé mais si vous
incluez les gorilles et les chimpanzés
dans l'origine de l'humanité
faudrait peut-être le dire dès le départ
voilà donc et là il n'ya pas d'erreur
d'interprétation possible
au début il parle très clairement de la
lignée humaine après sa divergence avec
le chimpanzé pas avant voilà donc au
départ ils définissent très bien ce
qu'ils entendent par lignée humaine et
soudainement à la fin pouf il change
d'avis et non en fait c'est l'origine
européenne des hominidés gorille
chimpanzé humain bah oui mais ça une
origine européenne des hominidés
ça n'est pas nouveau je le répète ça
n'est pas nouveau ce n'est pas ça ne
secoue pas des paradigmes établi
c'est à la limite ça vous secoue des
quelques idées reçues éventuellement si
vous aviez des idées reçues sur le sujet
mais voilà c'est tout c'est probablement
une question que vous vous posiez même
pas d'où venaient les hominidés au même
voilà donc à la limite
le documentaire a ce mérite là il vous a
fait vous posez la question de bah oui
c'est vrai le chimpanzé le gorille mais
d'où ils viennent mais bon tant qu'on a
le chimpanzé elghorri comme comme groupe
frère c'est à dire comme animaux les
plus proches parents des humains
l'origine humaine elle est toujours en
afrique même si l'ancêtre commun tout ce
beau monde vient d'europe l'origine de
la divergence humains chimpanzé elle
elle est enracinée en afrique et c'est
tout voilà le deuxième problème de ce
documentaire et c'est quelque chose qui
m'énerve excessivement dans beaucoup
beaucoup de documentaires quand il
s'agit de l'évolution humaine c'est la
datation
à partir du moment où un truc est trouvé
et qu'il est plus vieux qu un autre
c'est forcément son ancêtre et ça ça me
met absolument hors de moi donc là
qu'est ce qu'ils ont trouvé ils ont
trouvé des grands singes qui viennent
d'europe et qui sont plus vieux que
toumaï horohorine et les autres
zhu min qu'on a découvert en afrique
alors forcément c'est leurs ancêtres
voilà et ça non c'est juste non ça ne
marche pas comme ça c'est pas aussi
simple que ça et j'en veux pour preuve
le fait que les datations qu'ils ont
fait dans ce documentaire justement
qu'il présente dans ce documentaire
elles ont été faites sur quoi sur les
girafes
elles ont été faites sur les girafes
alors c'est pas un problème de faire
l'adaptation sur les girafes évidemment
qu'on va pas faire des petits trous dans
les fossiles d'homininés pour essayer de
voir deux camps il date est évidemment
mais le truc c'est que si vous si vous
n'utilisez que la date comme un indice
de relations de parenté
ben c'est la girafe qui est l'ancêtre
des êtres humains c'est pas les
chimpanzés enfin c'est pas les grands
sages voilà donc il faut faut sauter
cette idée de la tête que plus ancien
est forcément égale ancêtres et ce
documentaire ne le fait pas c'est pas
une idée qui est seulement une
simplification c'est une idée qui est
incroyablement fausses vous n'êtes pas
l'ancêtre de quelque chose juste parce
que vous êtes plus anciens c'est une
condition pour être l'ancêtre mais c'est
pas forcément un signe que vous êtes
l'ancêtre je ne suis pas le prétendant
légitime au trône de france parce que
j'ai vécu après louis xiv
voilà le fait d'avoir vécu après louis
xiv ne fait pas de moi le descendant de
la famille royale
eh ben c'est pareil pour les grands
singes et sapho bien seul enfoncer dans
le crâne
parce que si la date était la seule
chose qui était importante et bas ce
serait la girafe l'ancêtre du mois vous
ne pourriez pas exclure le fait que la
girafe serait l'ancêtre des de la lignée
humaine et on pourrait me rétorquer que
c'est dans une volonté de simplification
que ça a été fait qu'on veut pas
bassines et les gens avec des arbres
phylogénétiques surtout qu'il faudrait
expliquer ce que phylogénie veut dire
etc
mais c'est pas plus simple d'expliquer
juste les choses comme ça c'est juste
faux c'est juste purement et simplement
faux et pour des raisons complètement
évidente
donc voilà ça ça me plaît pas du tout de
voir encore des documentaires sortir
aujourd'hui en 2020 où on nous on nous
tracent une ligne droite dans le temps
et on nous place les fossiles dessus on
nous dit voilà c'est comme ça que les
trucs ont évolué c'est pas si simple
c'est pas du tout
simple aussi simple que ça donc pour
conclure sur cette première partie de
vidéos
qu'est ce que je pense de ce
documentaire il est pas mal
il al'avantage de montrer des fossiles
il al'avantage de montrer une vraie
démarche scientifique
il a par contre l'énorme inconvénient de
vous mentir de vous vendre une
conclusion qu'il ne vous donne pas la
fin un donc de vous vendre une
révolution scientifique l'origine
africaine de l'homme tout ça pour au
final retourné sa veste dans les 45
dernières secondes et finalement dire là
c'était les hominidés en fait quand on
parlait donc tout en entretenant un flou
artistique entre les définitions
justement de l'humanité versus hominidés
et puis bah surtout la science qu'il
vous vend n'est pas bonne les elle est
complètement dépassée tracé des lignes
droites avec et poser des faux cils
dessus en fonction du temps c'est pas
comme ça qu'on trace les liens de
parenté ou en 2020 et si vous ne l'avez
pas déjà vu est ce que je vous
recommanderais d'aller le voir ou de le
montrer à quelqu'un d'autre
la réponse est éventuellement oui
peut-être pour voir ce qui est un bon
documentaire sur la paléontologie
par contre gardez bien à l'esprit que
qu'au final ce documentaire vous ment
voilà c'est tout maintenant je passe à
la deuxième partie de cette vidéo où là
je vais commencer à devenir extrêmement
techniques extrêmement pointues
je vais vraiment commencé à décortiquer
le documentaire ainsi que son contexte
d'ailleurs je vais faire beaucoup de
contexte et plus et pas tellement
beaucoup de documentaires pour être tout
à fait honnête
une première chose à propos du contexte
qui me semblent importantes à savoir
pour vous c'est où est ce que je me
place mois par rapport à une à l'idée
d'une origine européenne de la lignée
humaine donc à une idée à l'idée d'une
origine européenne des homininés faut
savoir que je n'y suis pas opposé
je suis pas forcément un extrémiste de
l'origine africaine c'est jusque on a
des tonnes et des tonnes de fossiles en
afrique qui tracent très très bien
l'origine d'homo sapiens en afrique puis
du genre homo en afrique puis du genre
homo parmi les australopithèques
d'afrique puis des australopithèques
d'afrique parmi ardipithecus et or or in
jusqu'à toumaï donc jusqu'à 7 millions
six à sept millions d'années
on a une série continue de fossiles qui
documentent parfaitement l'origine
africaine de l'homme de des homininés
donc mais je suis pas opposé
fondamentalement à ce qu'un jour
peut-être on trouve une preuve que avant
toumaï il y avait des hominidés en
europe des homininés en europe ça je
suis pas complètement je suis pas
complètement opposé à cette idée alors
il ya des gens qui sont complètement
opposés à l'idée parce qu'il trouve
qu'il ya un roulante 19e siècle et
doropo centrisme quasi coloniale dans sa
mais voilà moi je j'y suis pas
particulièrement posé même au 19e siècle
au final il avait des bons arguments
pour considérer que l'être humain était
originaire d'europe ou d'asie
il avait des fossiles que en europe et
en asie à l'époque il n'avait que homo
neandertalensis homo heidelbergensis
donc les deux et ont été découverts en
europe et ils avaient homo erectus
l'homme de java en bas en asie
donc au final c'était pas déraisonnable
au 19e siècle de penser que l'homme
était originaire de ghazi c'est juste
que depuis on a découvert comme je vous
ai dit des tonnes de fossiles en afrique
qui ont prouvé le contraire
donc voilà si maintenant on se met à
découvrir des tonnes de fossiles qui
prouve qu'en fait avant tout my avant ça
elle entre aux puces
l'évolution de l'homme avait lieu en
europe
bon bah voilà on est prêts on est prêt à
se plier un je veux dire c'est pas une
origine européenne des homininés
d'autant pas un problème qu'il y a une
énorme diversité de sage en europe au
mieux celle supérieure est
essentiellement des grands singes
essentiellement des hominoïdes vous avez
pierrot la pythie cus j'ai parlé de rio
pittacus tout à l'heure où hadopi
t'accuse aurait hôpitaux cus le fameux
gréco pittacus dont il est question dans
le documentaire bref y'en a plein des
grands singes à l'époque en europe
l'europe
c'était un centre de diversité majeur
des grands singes ont mis en scène
supérieur donc pile à l'époque où les
eaux minini divergent des chimpanzés
donc il n'est pas impossible de trouver
l'origine des homininés en europe
c'est juste que jusqu'à présent bas il
n'existe aucun de ces grands singes
européen qui montre des traits des
caractères morphologiques qui les lie
définitivement aux hominidés aux mini
mais c'est pas impossible qu'on en
trouve un jour donc voilà qu'est ce qui
me convaincrait au final qu'est-ce qui
me convaincrait d'une origine non
africaines de des zones minini et ben ce
serait tout simplement de découvrir une
espèce qui est plus proche de la lignée
humaine que ne l'est le chimpanzé
découvrir une espèce qui n'est pas
africaine et qui vient se brancher à la
base de la branche qui a donné les
humains leur faudrait même plusieurs en
réalité parce que il ya quand même il
faut quand même compenser le fait que
nos deux groupes frère donc les deux que
les deux groupes qui sont les plus
proches de nous c'est le groupe des
pannes in et donc les chimpanzés et le
groupe des gorilles in et celui des
gorilles donc il faut comprendre il faut
arriver à compenser le fait qu'on a
quand même deux groupes frère en afrique
donc on est vraiment solidement
enracinée en afrique donc il faudrait
trouver beaucoup d'espèces en europe ou
ailleurs qui montre que en fait qui se
sont plus proches de nous mais qui sont
sur un autre continent
en gros ou alors il faudrait arriver à
démontrer que les chimpanzés et les
gorilles non pas une origine africaine
donc trouver des fossiles très ancien de
chimpanzés et des gorilles qui ont une
origine ailleurs qu'en afrique ça ça
pourrait aussi faire changer la balance
et c'est pas totalement impossible étant
donné qu'on a quasiment zéro registre
fossile de chimpanzés et gorilles
il existe aucun fossile mis en scène de
chimpanzés et je crois même qu'il y en a
pas non plus au pliocène ni au
pléistocène donc les braves alors on n'a
rien on niveau chimpanzés et un niveau
gorille on en a un au miocène supérieur
qu'aurora pittacus qui vivait il ya huit
millions d'années et même là c'est juste
quelques dents donc c'est pas grand
chose
il se pourrait très bien que ce soit des
dents qui ressemble superficiellement à
ça à celle d'un gorille mais que
l'animal en lui même n'était pas un
gorille s'est pas complètement
impossible mais voilà il ya quand même
des choses qui seraient convaincante en
tant que preuve d'une origine des
homininés en dehors d'afrique mais
aucune d'entre elles je vous rassure on
est montré dans ce documentaire aucune
aucune d'entre elles dans ce
documentaire il vous montre
il vous montre gréco pittacus qui est
alors qui fait partie typiquement de ces
fossiles qui font dire aux gens que les
paléontologues fonds des grandes
théories à pâtir de que dalle parce que
là sérieusement je crois pas que
quelqu'un ait vu ce documentaire et vu
la tronche du fossile de greco pitt et
cus et se soient dit waouh ça crève les
yeux
c'est pas possible que vous ayez vu
cette mâchoire dégoûtante avec des dents
tout usé et que vous vous soyez dit bah
oui c'est totalement je suis convaincu
je suis vendu quoi ça y est
non gréco pittacus c'est une petite
mâchoire tout usé la seule façon dont
ils l'ont date et je tiens je sais pas
si vous avez remarqué dans le
documentaire mais il faut qu'il dise
quand même ils ont daté la mâchoire de
sept millions d'années parce qu'ils ont
trouvé une dent en bulgarie alors que la
mâchoire vient de grèce et que selon eux
cette dent de bulgarie date de sept
millions d'années et appartient à gries
copie tqs ça fait quand même beaucoup
d'angle à arrondir et de très attirés de
raccourci à prendre juste pour arriver à
la conclusion que gréco pittacus est
plus vieux que toumaï et que donc il est
l'ancêtre de la lignée humaine sachant
que c'est pas vrai de toute façon c'est
pas juste parce qu'il est plus ancien
que c'est forcément l'ancêtre de la
lignée humaine
il ya par contre un caractère dont il
parle et qui est intéressant c'est le
caractère de la fusion des racines donc
chez les chez les hominidés donc dans la
lignée humaine
les racines de la deuxième prémolaires
sont fusionnés elles ne le sont pas chez
le chimpanzé est donc apparemment chez
gréco pitt et qu elle serait
partiellement fusionner alors c'est un
caractère qui a l'air de fonctionner
quand on vous le présente dans le
documentaire parce qu'évidemment on ne
vous présente que les cas où ça marche
bien on vous présente pas les cas où ça
marche pas et en l'occurrence on sait
que chez les chimpanzés il arrive
parfois que les racines de la q2 la
deuxième prémolaires soient fusionnées
donc c'est un caractère qui est variable
chez le chimpanzé il est pas totalement
absent chez le chimpanzé donc il n'est
pas totalement impossible que cela était
aussi le cas chez gréco pittacus donc on
a vraiment que très très peu de
caractère qui permettent de dire
vraiment si gréco pitt et cus et est
relié au zoo min
ou pas autrefois gréco pittacus était
même synonyme avait cours à nos pitt et
cusset houran au pit et cuche n'a jamais
été considéré comme étant plus proches
des zones minées dans les analyse
phylogénétique donc on peut passer au
second faisceau de preuves qui est
présenté dans ce documentaire est celui
là est beaucoup plus intéressant il
s'agit des empreintes de pas les
empreintes de pas qu'il présente sont
définitivement très très intéressante
parce qu elles ont effectivement une
morphologie qui est très très très très
similaire à celle de l'homme et je pense
que dans le documentaire il exclut très
très efficacement la possibilité que ça
puisse être que ça ait pu être fait par
un bipède non obligatoire il montre bien
l'alignement des orteils il montre bien
la taille décroissante des orteils
il montre il montre bien que le pouce
opposable et pacy opposable que ça il ya
aussi un truc qui est très intéressant
c'est la petite taille de ses empreintes
un évidemment quand on parle de
l'évolution de l'homme on parle aussi de
l'augmentation de la taille de l'homme
durant la lignée humaine donc là c'est
en prêtent elles sont vraiment très
petit elles ont vraiment cette
morphologie qu'on s'attend à voir chez
un hominidé anciens presque même trop
avancée par rapport à celle d'un
australopithèque j'ai envie de dire la
morphologie de ses empreintes
elle fait vraiment penser à un pied
quasiment moderne quoi par la légère aux
possibilités du pouce elles sont presque
plus avancé que les empreintes de
l'artolie dans la lignée humaine donc
donc c'est plutôt intéressant et alors
dans le documentaire par contre une fois
de plus ils font ils entretiennent un
flou artistique sur la date de ces
fossiles en l'occurrence ils disent
environ 6 millions d'années donc environ
6 millions d'années ça les rend aussi
vieille que horohorine alors ses
empreintes serai plus vieille corinne ou
au moins aussi vieille que rory n'est
que toumaï ce qui pourrait là pour le
coup placé le
les eaux minini en europe avant
l'afrique
là ça marcherait oui mais comme je les
dis ils font exprès d'entretenir le flou
sur la véritable date qui est en réalité
de 5,7 millions d'années la date de ses
empreintes quand vous allez voir la
littérature scientifique allaient en
fait de 5,7 millions d'années ce qui la
place ce qui les place en fait juste à
la fin de doro rinne en fait donc il ya
le à l'espèce de fourchette de dates
qu'on a pour origine de 6 à 5,7 millions
d'années bah en fait voilà ça les places
juste à la fin juste un peu plus jeunes
en fait corps auryn donc il ya déjà
définitivement des homininés en afrique
plus vieux que ses empreintes donc
pareil c'est perdu c'est ça disqualifie
les empreintes encore que comme je le
dis c'est très intéressant c'est très
intéressant parce qu un bipède comme ça
en europe basse soit faut admettre que
ce sont les hommes les bipèdes africains
qui ont traversé d'une façon ou d'une
autre la méditerranée enfin qu'ils ont
fait tout le tour de la méditerranée
pour arriver là et dans ce cas c'est la
première preuve qu'on aurait d'homininés
domini ni en europe qui auraient
traversé qui se seraient dispersés hors
d'afrique
imaginez des australes avant même
australopithèques dispersé hors
d'afrique
ou alors il faudrait admettre une
convergence évolutive magistral entre
des grands singes européens et des
homininés d'afrique convergence
évolutive qui est très très peu probable
puisqu'il y à 5,7 millions d'années si
je ne m'abuse il reste plus grand monde
de grands singes en europe faut savoir
qu'il ya un grand remplacement qui a
lieu à la fin du miocène des grands
singes parler cercopithèque au heat donc
les sarko pitt et coheed ce sont les
babouins les macaques etc et donc avant
le milieu scène supérieur il y avait
énormément de grands singes en afrique
en europe et en asie et après le mit en
scène supérieur il y en a quasiment plus
les grands singes sont une famille en
voie d'extinction ils le sont toujours
et donc ça commence par l'afrique donc à
la fin d'une à la fin du miocène
supérieur l'afrique a déjà perdu la
plupart de ces grands singes et puis
après ça se répand jusqu en europe
au début du pliocène et bien les
derniers grands singes commence à ces
tables dont khl à 5,7 millions d'années
on est toujours au mit en scène
supérieur il est toujours censé y avoir
des grands sages mais il y en a de moins
en moins donc est ce que c'est encore
possible qu'on puisse voir un grand
singe s'adapter à une bipédie permanente
de façon parallèle aux hommes c'est pas
totalement impossible puisque comme elle
dit il ya un environnement de savane qui
seraient propices à un scénario
similaire à celui de l'origine de la
bipédie humaine encore que pareil là je
m'appuie sur le scénario east liste side
story qui est très contesté donc bon ça
ça se discute ça se discute mais les
intéressants voilà et le troisième
faisceau de preuves qu'il présente et
bien c'est danubius danube yeux ce qui
est un tout nouveau fossile qui a été
décrit l'année dernière j'ai fait toute
une vidéo dessus que je vous encourage à
aller voir si vous voulez en savoir plus
donc danubius s'éteint c'est un grand
sage et y les bipèdes
du moins c'est ce que son squelette à
l'air d'indiquer est là pour le coup
c'est pas comme c'est pas comme gréco
pittacus où on n'a que des rogatons dont
on ne sait pas quoi faire
danut vieux s'il est bien préservé on a
un squelette qui est quasiment entiers
il a un peu écrasée il est pas il est
pas très joli mais il est entier voilà
bon et dans le dans le film ils disent
ah enfin dans le documentaire il 10 à
14% il a l'air d'y avoir un peu plus que
14% mais bon bref c'est pas c'est pas si
important et surtout on a le fémur on a
le fémur qui permet définitivement de
dire s'il était bipède ou non donc on
est peut-être en train de regarder un
bipède arboricole en parlant de fémur il
présente un fémur de possibles gré copie
tech dans le documentaire
comme ils n'ont pas encore étudié je
sais pas trop quoi en dire j'ai pas
l'impression que ça fasse que ce soit
vraiment un film sûrs de bipèdes mais on
verra ce que les vrais spécialistes en
dirons de ce fémur de greco pitt et cusm
est en tout cas danube yeux' apparemment
lui sont faits murs et du bipède et donc
avec danubius on tiendrait un bipède
obligatoire possiblement un bipède
arboricole donc comme un gibbons ou un
orang outan par exemple qui vivait en
europe à la bonne tranche de temps etc
un bon candidat à l'origine de
l'humanité oui mais hélas je vais vous
passez un extrait de la vidéo que
j'avais fait justement sur danubius elle
est où la phylogénie elle est où la
phylogénie la regarder c'est le
générique de fin la sas et tout ça c'est
le générique de fin août
bordel elle est où la phylogénie voilà
c'est là quand c'est là qu'on parle de
phylogénie c'est maintenant qu'on
attaque la phylogénie quand vous avez un
fossile qui est sur le point de
révolutionner comme ça le paradigme
scientifique vous fait pas les choses à
moitié
vous fait pas les choses à moitié vous
vous arrêtez pas à simplement dire ah
ben voilà ça vivait avant toumaï alors
c'est forcément l'ancêtre à toumaï non
on fait plus ça en 2020 en 2020 on fait
d analyse phylogénétique une analyse
phylogénétique c'est indispensable
pourquoi parce que c'est une façon de
construire un arbre évolutif du vivant
de façon reproductible on formalise les
observations dans un tableau et on
traite ce tableau en utilisant une
méthode statistique qui nous renvoie un
arbre et on décide si cet arbre
reflètent ou non la vraie évolution du
vivant donc la seule partie où vous
émettez une opinion dans le processus et
au moment où vous décider si oui ou non
l'arbre est correct en gros et tout le
reste c'est totalement reproductible il
n'ya pas d'opinion c'est de la science
c'est de la vrai dans la plus pure
définition du terme la définition la
plus pop et rienne du terme donc la
phylogénie c'est indispensable si vous
me prenez un grand sage bipèdes comme
danubius et que d'un seul coup vous dit
il et bipèdes c'est forcément l'ancêtre
de l'homme en plus y vivaient avant
banon vous n'excluez pas la possibilité
d' évolution convergente de la bipédie
vous ne montrez pas que danube youth et
plus proches des humains qu'ils ne
l'aient d'autres grands singes bipèdes
parce que je voulais dit laurent où tu
en es bipèdes arboricole may be paid
quand même et puis on a d'autres grands
singes qui était bipède arboricole
potentiel comme par exemple aurait au
pit et cus qui vient du miocène d'italie
on a aura nos pittacus qui était aussi
possiblement bipèdes donc voilà on a
beaucoup de candidats comme possible
proche pas
danut vieux il n'y a pas que les êtres
humains qui sont bipèdes les êtres
humains ils sont bipèdes terrestre
obligatoire mais ils ont aussi d'autres
caractères qu'il faut mettre en avant
ils ont aussi des caractéristiques
dentaire qui les rend uniques notamment
l'usure apicale de la canine mais c'est
pareil
juste trouver l'usure de apicale de la
canine ça suffirait pas parce que ça
aussi c'est un caractère qu'on trouve
ailleurs notamment chez gigan topi tech
par exemple vous voyez c'est pour ça
qu'il faut formaliser
toutes ces observations je dis bien
toutes les observations pas seulement
celle qui nous arrange pas seulement la
bipédie faut tout les formaliser dans un
tableau faire traiter ce tableau d'une
façon statistique reproductibles et
après seulement après prendre une
décision sur oui ou non notre notre
espèce et elles reliées
phylogénétiquement aux humains ou pas
voilà et ça c'est pas un problème et ça
c'est pas un problème du documentaire
c'est le problème des scientifiques à la
base qui ont publié sur dani view ce
donc là c'est juste le documentaire qui
reflète exactement les scientifiques ce
que ce que n'ont pas fait les
scientifiques en fait c'est des
scientifiques qui pensent qu'ils
réfléchissent encore en dehors d'un
cadre phylogénétique et je ne sais pas
comment c'est possible aujourd'hui
d'arriver à publier les choses comme ça
je sais pas parce que là vraiment c'est
négliger le point le plus important de
votre démonstration
vous voulez montrer que danubius est
fils génétiquement relié à l'homme fait
une analyse phylogénétique n'y allez pas
au pifomètre
parce que c'est tout ce qui reste c'est
ça le problème c'est qu'à la fin c'est
tout ce qui reste tout ce qu'ils nous
disent c'est que dany views ces applis
hoplite et si des alors oui les plie aux
politesses idées sont connus pour être
plus ou moins étroitement apparentées
aux minimes des pas aux mini ni d'où la
conclusion finale du documentaire les
hominidés ont peut être une origine
européenne
bah oui mais c'est pas ça que tu nous
promettait tu nous promettait une
origine européenne des eaux minini pas
des hominidés
voilà donc
donc c'est vraiment un énorme problème
d'avoir cette négligence totale de la
phylogénie dans le documentaire essais
et voilà maintenant que je voulais dire
vous pouvez revoir ce documentaire et
vous et vous dire bah oui là il y aurait
tellement fallu un arbre phylogénétique
pour l'expliquer ça aurait été tellement
plus claire maintenant il ya qu un seul
arbre phylogénétique il est au tout
début il n'y a pas de faux cils et on en
vient presque à suspecter que la raison
pour laquelle n'y a pas de faux cils
c'est parce que s'ils essayaient de les
placer dessus ça montrerait qu'ils ont
tort d'un bout à l'autre ça enlèverait
complètement le doute sur le fait que au
mini hominidés qui c'est qui est
européen qui sait qu'il est pas voilà
tout de suite évidemment ça les vrais le
doute puisque on aurait toujours le
chimpanzé gorille qui serait le plus
proche parent de l'homme donc une
origine profondément africaine pour le
genre humain
voilà donc plus de suspense alors pour
finir si on dresse un petit bilan de
tout ça on a les trois gros argument un
gréco pittacus les pistes d'empreintes
et danube use d'un grec au pit et cus
trop fragmentaires les pistes d'emprunt
enfin la piste d'empreintes de pas c'est
intéressant mais ça ne démontre pas en
soi même une origine européenne de la
lignée humaine et danube use bas il
manque la moitié du boulot va là bas il
manque la moitié du boulot quand vous
imaginez que ça a été publié dans une
grande revue en plus danubius c'est
triste à voir quoi donc on attend
l'autre moitié du travail
ils ont déjà annoncé qu'un jour
peut-être il publierait autre chose ce
serait dommage de laisser en plan on
peut être que là une fois que ce sera
publié il sera temps de faire
un documentaire sur la possible origine
européenne des êtres humains mais pour
l'instant en tout cas clairement ce
documentaire a été fait beaucoup trop
tôt avec trop peu de matériel voilà je
vous remercie à tous d'avoir tenu jusque
là et je vous dis à très bientôt sur la
prochaine
ciao